DVDs popularity has risen alongside the
controversial legalization of marijuana
doctors are recommending it and many
people are self prescribing it people
with arthritis ms and lupus are turning
to products like CBD infused lotion to
help manage their pain while some rub it
on their feet for a night out in heels
we took a look at the products
effectiveness and the growing business
behind them it really just helped me get
ahold of my gut issues 26 year old Jules
hunt is a new york-based wellness
blogger
about two months ago she started taking
CBD oil once a day put it under your
tongue hunt told us the oil recommended
to her by her doctor helps her stomach
problems and the anxiety that comes with
them what did you first notice when you
started to use it I think you start to
feel a benefits over time and then you
realize oh wow I slept a lot better that
you think I didn't wake up in a panic
thinking about my long to-do list for
the next day CBD is one of many
compounds derived from cannabis another
is THC the main psychoactive compound in
marijuana
unlike THC pure CBD products won't
produce a euphoric effect the actual
effectiveness from a scientific point of
view is really difficult to define but
Drake University clinical Sciences chair
Tim Welty says it's difficult to know
how well the supplements work although
limited studies show CBD helps with
epilepsy he says there are potential
side effects browsing us is common and
then GI complaints then there's a
potential concern about damage to the
liver
last year the FDA sent letters to for
CBD manufacturers alleging some products
didn't contain the levels of CBD they
claim to have CBD is largely unregulated
so you could be getting something in
your oil that you may not have wanted to
get is that a concern for you that's why
you have to do your research you
definitely don't want to just buy any
CBD oil out there you want to talk to
your doctor who can recommend the
cleanest forms out there despite the
unknown the CBD industry is growing
cannabis data analytics firm new
frontier data predicts CBD sales will
nearly quadruple over the next four
years
and we've seen our sales grow tenfold in
the past year okay Rob Rosen heck and
his wife Cindy Capobianco are
co-founders of the california-based
company Lord Jones the company's
wellness lotion is a customer favorite
they'll use it before a workout or after
workout for recovery they'll use it for
skin conditions from eczema to psoriasis
to sunburn headaches and neck aches
joint pain we've had steady growth in
Washington DC celebrity chef Spike
Mendelsohn is finding success with his
CBD infused water business
it's another plant it's just like matcha
it's just like a coffee bean it has just
gotten a bad rap from marijuana though
hunt is feeling the benefits of CBD she
doesn't think it's the only reason her
health has improved I think it's a
combination of things a really healthy
diet avoiding my allergens taking CBD
oil and following the supplements that
my doctor prescribed to me that in
combination is making me feel better as
a whole we spoke to Jules hunts doctor
who told us she's recommended CBD oil to
dozens of patients for migraines bowel
conditions insomnia and menstrual cramps
she says the oil is often a last resort
for people who have unsuccessfully tried
other solutions she urges patients to be
careful about using CBD if they're
already taking other medications
what was the part about the high heels
part putting on your foot on your feet
that's what you're interested in Gail
yeah it's sort of kind of yeah yeah news
you can use
yeah well it's in lotion and a lot of
people rub it on their feet things like
that the lord jones high inflammatory
and pain relieving at Laura Jones very
pretty packaging yes thank you